un manquement numéro 14 846 merci madame
la Présidente donc Madame Élisabeth
borne considère qu'elle n'a aucun état
d'âme à faire cette réforme ce sont les
mots d'un bourreau ce ne sont pas les
mots d'une première ministre ce sont les
mots d'un bourreau aucun
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne
travaille et comment peut-être
s'exprimer de cette façon là quelle
fierté retire-t-elle à parler comme ça
aux gens qui ne sont pas d'accord pour
sacrifier deux ans de leur vie au
travail en plus alors que rien ne le
justifie
vous étiez en colère qu'on vous dise que
vous étiez peut-être des monstres mais
là c'est un bourreau qui s'exprime
madame la Première ministre c'est ce
qu'elle est point final les saboteurs du
service public voilà de quoi on parle
maintenant des saboteurs du service
public vous vous attaquez au régime
spéciaux des agents de service public
quel est le problème avec les régimes
spéciaux des agents de service public ce
sont des régimes avancés pionniers qui
rote attractif le métier d'agent de
service au public voilà ce que vous êtes
en train de saccager voilà ce que nous
sommes fiers de défendre encore ce matin
avec force et voilà pourquoi demain
j'appelle et j'ai fait des listes
monsieur Maillard j'appelle les
électriciens et les gaziers
j'appelle les agents de la RATP
j'appelle les salariés de la Banque de
France
j'appelle les conseillers du 16e
j'appelle tout seuls que vous visez par
votre réforme à manifester demain
merci appelle à nous rej
oindre non à votre réforme merci
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente et c'est au
titre de l'article 10 70 alinéa 2 mal
nommé les choses c'est rajouter de la
malheur du malheur au monde et les
propos qui viennent d'être tenus où on
parle de bourreau ou on qualifie la
première ministre de bourreau c'est
inacceptable inacceptable on peut
critiquer cette réforme des retraites il
y a la démocratie sociale dans la rue il
y a la démocratie politique qui se joue
ici mais les propos que vous tenez sont
inacceptables et puis vous dire quoi ça
embarrasse même des gens qui sont dans
votre groupe c'est insupportable
comme